السباق نحو رئاسه البيت الابيض يتطلب
تحضيرا كافيا وان كان راي العام الامريكي
والدولي يركز على الرئيسين الحالي جو
بايدن والسابق دونالد ترامب فان مهمتهما
تمر اولا عبر تجاوز منافسين محتملين داخل
حزبيهما الاكيد ان داخل الحزب الديمقراطي
يبرز بدرجه اولى اسم رئيس الحالي بايدن
كمرشح رئيسي لكن بايدن سيجد منافسه مرشح
يحمل اسما كافيا لجذب الانظار بشكل كبير
الحديث هنا عن روبرت كينيدي جونيور ابني
شقيق الرئيس الامريكي السابق جون كينيدي
كما سيواجه بايدن مره اخرى منافسه الكاتبه
ماريان ويليام سون التي كانت ترشحت في
الانتخابات التمهيديه السابقه اما فيما
يخص المرشحين المتوقعين الى حد ما فهناك
اسماء ذات شعبيه كبيره مثل حاكمه ولايه
ميتشيغان جريتشنر والمحامي
فضلا عن وزير النقل الحالي
على الطرف الاخر فان الاسم الاكثر تداولا
وشعبيه لدى الجمهوريين هو الرئيس السابق
دونالد ترامب لكن انتزاعه تزكيه الحزب
الجمهوري يتطلب تجاوز بعض الاسماء القويه
ياتي على راسها الحاكم السابق لولايه
اركان
والذي لا يتردد في دعوه
على اصوات الجمهوريين ويتعلق الامر بنكي
هايلي الحاكمات السابقه لولايه
اما مرشح ظل داخل الحزب الجمهوري فيتقدمهم
حاكم ولايه فلوريدا الى جانب رئيس
الامريكي السابق ومن فريق ترامبا السابق
دائما يبرز اسم وزير الخارجيه السابق مايك
وكلها شخصيات لم تعلن ترشحها بشكل رسمي
لحد الان وسام الذهبي العربيه
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات